[Musique]
nous avons choisi Strasbourg parce que
c'est une métropole qui est en avance
sur un certain nombre de sujets de
mobilité la métropole de Strasbourg a
été très précurseur sur le transport en
commun il est intéressant de voir
comment les choses évoluent au niveau de
la zone affaiblissement
et
aller les jours de marché pour
l'ensemble de toutes les communes à
toutes nos épates effectivement fait par
mail ou par réunion mais aller vers
notamment par rapport aux gens modeste
il y a un dialogue qui existe une
certaine efficacité pour autant les uns
et les autres sont toujours assez
réservés sur les implications et sur les
conséquences que sont susceptibles
d'avoir la mise en place un peu trop
rapide des zones affaiblissement
de s'en sortir avec cette difficulté on
doit tirer parti du périmètre européen
des expériences européennes sur ces
questions là
vous êtes à l'agence du climat ou le
guichet des solutions
au niveau de leur métropole 80% des
trajets font moins de 3 km alors si on
se dit que c'est moins de 3 km peuvent
être fait à pied ou à vélo ou un
transport en commun c'est déjà 80% des
véhicules qu'on évite je crois qu'il
faut du dialogue de la compréhension de
l'échange et que tout le monde puisse
faire un effort pour autant il faut que
ce soit clairement exposé et que ces
mesures soient comprises par nos
concitoyens qu'elles soient acceptables
qu'elles soient accompagnées dans le
cadre d'une Concorde républicaine dans
notre pays aujourd'hui plus que jamais a
bien besoin
[Musique]